you
well I think John Adams with his sense
of history would have laughed at any use
of the word dynasty for one generation
is succeeding as another generation in
the office of the presidency that two
generations does not a dynasty make if
if any one family had occupied executive
power held executive power under our
system for three or four or five or six
or ten generations then that might be
constitute as it as a dynasty no I think
that like a lot of things that people
say today it really doesn't have much
historic validity when people say for
example that about days gone by and
let's say the days gone by of 18th
century America oh that was a simpler
time they didn't have to contend with
the complexities and difficulties that
beset our time that was a simpler time
anybody that ever says that has no sense
of history doesn't know it he she is
talking about there was no simpler time
ever different time but not simpler and
I think anyone who watches this series
when when the realities of smallpox the
realities of medicine without the
benefit of anesthetics the reality of
epidemic disease the reality of very
difficult often horrendously dangerous
transportation come through in the film
they'll never think that those people in
our founding day lived in the simpler
time ever again